Sì.
Quando guardi le capacità odierne, penso che sia
anche una domanda molto importante: chiedersi beh,
qual è la roadmap, cioè quanto
migliori stanno diventando questi sistemi
e quanto più complessi
saranno i circuit che riusciremo a eseguire.
Per rispondere a questo abbiamo sviluppato una metrica molto importante
chiamata quantum volume.
A volte potresti leggere o sentire nella stampa divulgativa
il numero di qubit, sai,
come misura del progresso.
Ti dico chiaramente che
il solo numero di qubit nella macchina non è una
buona misura del progresso.
Il progresso deve essere misurato in base
al livello di complessità del circuit che riesci a eseguire.
I qubit in queste buone macchine non sono perfetti oggi,
e hanno errori introdotti dall'accoppiamento del
sistema con il mondo esterno.
La stessa potenza di questi qubit,
dell'entanglement e di quelle proprietà,
li rende al tempo stesso potenti
e delicati rispetto all'interazione
e alla connessione con il mondo esterno.
Quindi devi abbassare il tasso di errore
mentre aumenti il numero di qubit.
Ecco cosa è rappresentato qui:
quello che vuoi davvero fare è muoverti in diagonale,
e il quantum volume è una misura che incorpora
entrambe quelle metriche e alcune considerazioni aggiuntive chiave.